جائحة ما هو جائحة ما الذي تراه عندما تنظر إلى هذا الشريط من الواضح أنه هناك وبالتأكيد ليس تباعدًا اجتماعيًا ولا يرتدي أقنعة هؤلاء هم أصدقائي هناك هذه هي الولاية التالية لاستضافة تجمع رئاسي في أريزونا وهي نقطة ساخنة متنامية 19 kovat وموطنًا ل قتال حول الأقنعة ، انظر إلى أعلى وأسفل الشارع وتأثير الفيروس في كل مكان لا تزال بعض الشركات تغلق اللافتات الساطعة التي يرتديها أحد عمال البار في قناع اجتماعيًا ، لكن العديد من سكان تيمبي أريزونا ، سيستمر هذا في التفاقم. حتى نفعل شيئًا حيال ذلك ، لا أرتدي قناعًا - أعتقد أن الأقنعة جيدة ولكن أعتقد أنها تعمل نوعًا ما كعلاج وهمي إلى حد ما لدي عائلة شخصياً فقدت فيروس كورونا لذا يجب أن أرتديها قناع لكنني لست ما لست عليه مع أصدقائي ، إنه يتجاهلني وأحاول أن أكون هادئًا لهذا المحاور للكاميرا د.  المزيد
ممثل Tosa هو طبيب غرفة الطوارئ
في فينيكس حيث يرى زيادة كبيرة
في مرضى COBIT تمامًا مثل
بقية الولاية ، وهذا ما
حدث للحالات في أريزونا منذ مارس ، حيث
يستمر عدد الحالات الجديدة في
تحطيم الأرقام القياسية كل يوم تقريبًا هذا الأسبوع
كانت أريزونا من بين الولايات الأولى التي
أعادت فتح الأعمال التجارية مرة أخرى ،
وتبع ذلك التجمعات مثل الاحتجاجات على وحشية الشرطة
والجماعية في الأماكن العامة كما رأينا
في تيمبي ، ولم تكن تستخدم دائمًا لإخبار
العالم بأسره أنني في الأساس
داروين اجتماعي إذا مت ، فأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  أنا فقط
أريد الجعة والبرغر هي حقًا
أعني أنه حتى أطفال رياض الأطفال لديهم المزيد من
التعاطف مع الآخرين ، إنه أمر
مزعج حقًا يا
دكتور.  octor هو واحد من أكثر من 3000
طبيب وممرض للتوقيع على هذه
الرسالة ، والهدف من ذلك هو حمل حاكم ولاية أريزونا على
إصدار تفويض على مستوى الولاية يتطلب
كتابة الأقنعة ، يرجى الوقوف والمساعدة في
تثقيف وحماية أولئك الذين
لا يفهمون أهمية الأقنعة
بدلاً من ذلك.  يقول إنه سيترك
تلك السياسات ،
يفعل كل رئيس بلدية يقول حاكم
ولايتنا إنني سأذهب إلى ما يقرره رئيس البلدية ،
أعني أنه من المحتمل أن يقول رئيس البلدية
أنني سأترك
الحي يقرره وكما يمكنك أن
تتخيل أن ذلك ينهار بسرعة كبيرة
غير فعال غير فعال بقدر ما
يمكن أن يكون علنًا ، تحول الحاكم دوسي
الأسبوع الماضي في مؤتمره الصحفي الأسبوعي
الذي حمل قناعه في
جيبه هذا الأسبوع ووصل مرتديًا القناع
بينما يستعد العصير ولايته
لاستضافة الرئيس الذي لا يقنع على الدوام يوم
الثلاثاء لحضور تجمع حاشد في  كنيسة ضخمة داخلية
يقول الحاكم إن بروتوكول البيت الأبيض
سيدعو إلى ارتداء أقنعة
شدد دوسي على أن الحدث الذي يتسع لـ 3500 شخص يجب أن
يستمر ، وسنعمل على الاحتراف
هناك مخاوف بالفعل من اندلاع موجة ثانية في سقوط جائحة الرئيس المشترك ، والآن تقوم الحكومة بتجديد المخزون الوطني الاستراتيجي ليلى سانتياغو ، وتنضم إلينا الآن بمزيد من التفاصيل حول ذلك. حسنًا ، نعلم جيدًا ما يحاول مسؤولو الصحة الوصول إليه ، فنحن لا نعرف بالضبط ما يوجد في هذا المخزون في الوقت الحالي ، ومن المهم أن نلاحظ أن هذا يأتي في وقت نسمع فيه حقًا رسائل متضاربة تأتي من الإدارة يقول أحد المستشارين إنه لن تكون هناك موجة ثانية ، يقول أحدهم الآخر ، نعم ، إننا نعمل على تجديد الموارد استعدادًا لما يمكن أن يكون موجة ثانية من الأهمية بمكان ملاحظة ما يبحث عنه مسؤولو HHS هنا وهم يحاولون تحقيق ثلاثة أشياء إنهم لا يريدون الاعتماد كثيرًا على التوريد الأجنبي ، فهم يريدون إلقاء نظرة ثاقبة على سلسلة التوريد والخاصة في الشراكات العامة ، كما يرغبون في جعل  بالتأكيد لديهم
النطاق المناسب من المنتجات ، فماذا
يعني ذلك جيدًا أنهم ينظرون إلى
أسوأ 30 يومًا من الأشهر الخمسة الماضية
ويضربون ذلك في ثلاثة للحصول على
إمداد لمدة 90 يومًا ويأملون في القيام بذلك في
وقت متأخر  تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) ، تأتي هذه المعلومات
من مسؤول
الصحة في الخدمات الصحية والإنسانية ، وبالتالي فإن
القلق هو ما سيحدث إذا بدأنا قبل أواخر
تشرين الأول (أكتوبر) في رؤية هذا الانبعاث
بالطريقة الثانية التي يشعر بها الكثير من الناس
بالقلق وما نراه
كما أراه  تحدثنا إلى الكثير من المسؤولين في الولاية
أنهم لا ينتظرون الشهادة
الوطنية الاستراتيجية
التي يقولون عنها ، انظروا أننا سننشئ
مخزون الولاية الخاص بنا
لأول مرة حتى إذا حدث ذلك فيمكننا
أن نكون مستعدين
للاستماع فلنقارن  حالات جديدة طبيب
حالات جديدة في الولايات المتحدة وكندا وإيطاليا في
ألمانيا كلها باستثناء الولايات المتحدة تتجه نحو
الانخفاض في الواقع في الولايات المتحدة
تتجه في الواقع ، أعني أنه يبدو كما لو أننا استسلمنا
جيدًا ، لا أعتقد أننا استسلمنا
ولكن هناك اختلافات ثقافية كبيرة في
هذه البلدان الأخرى لديها
وعي اجتماعي كبير هنا نحن
أكثر فردانية وهذا هو تقليدنا الكامل
وهناك جميع أنواع
الأشخاص الذين يريدون فقط الخروج إلى هناك
ويقولون أنني أريد أن أكون أنا ، هذا ما
أريد أن أفعله ، لقد سئمت من حمى المقصورة هذه
، من الصعب جدًا إقناع الجميع
حقًا بارتداء تلك الأقنعة و  أن تتصرف
بطريقة حكيمة ، لذا أعتقد أن هذا
في المحتالين أعني أنني أعتقد أن
الفردية أو الفردية شيء واحد
ولكن تجاهل الحقائق أو عدم
الإيمان بالحقائق في العلم
أن هذا شيء آخر
يضعه الطبيب الذي كافح في وقت مبكر مثل
العديد من الدول في  الشمال الشرقي
يعمل الآن بشكل أفضل
بينما الولايات التي لم يكن لديها العديد من الحالات
في البداية تشهد الآن زيادات مفاجئة
خاصة في الجنوب وفي
الغرب لماذا نرى هذا التقليب
جيدًا أعتقد أنه كان هناك إضافة  بالنسبة
لما قلناه للتو ، أعتقد أنه كان هناك
أمل في أن يذهب كوفات في
إجازة صيفية وكان ذلك
متوقعًا حقًا لقد سمعت أن الكثير نوقش
في رقبتي من الغابة ولم يحدث هذا فقط.
كوفات لن تختفي ، إنها معنا
وسأكون معنا أخشى أن يكون هذا هو
المستقبل الجديد غير المريح ولكنه حقيقي
بعد ظهر هذا اليوم
.
قال أنتوني فوسي إنه قلق
مما أسماه تصاعدًا مزعجًا في
الإصابات بفيروس كورونا في بعض الولايات
ووصفها بأنها مزعجة للغاية وأن
الأسبوعين المقبلين حاسمان من أجل
السيطرة على الانتشار مع استمرار عدد
حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد.
شهد الارتفاع في نصف جميع الولايات و
13 ولاية بالأمس فقط عددًا قياسيًا
من الإصابات الجديدة
على الرغم من الانتشار ، تواصل إدارة ترامب
حتى الآن
خطتها لإنهاء التمويل لمواقع الاختبار
بعد أسبوع من اليوم حتى في
الولايات الأكثر تضررًا مثل  تكساس كولورادو
وإلينوي 13 موقعًا عبر خمس ولايات
إجمالاً على الرغم من خطأ الطبيب ، أكدت مرة
أخرى الأطفال الرضع اليوم على
أهمية الاختبار